madame monsieur bonsoir cette fois ça y
est le gouvernement a délivré
aujourd'hui l' ordonnance qui doit
mettre un terme au déficit de la
sécurité sociale 1 une maladie devenue
chronique depuis plusieurs années trois
mesures principales majoration
exceptionnel de 1 % pendant 18 mois des
cotisations maladie calculée sur le
salaire réel comme le seront d'ailleurs
l'ensemble des cotisations à partir de
janvier 1980 de plafonnement et contrôle
des dépenses des hôpitaux trois
suppressions de l'augmentation prévue
des tarifs des médecins remède de cheval
pour les uns pilule amère pour certains
plâtre sur une jambe de bois pour les
autres les commentaires sont déjà
nombreux nous allons y revenir notamment
avec deux invités le ministre la santé
monsieur jacques barrot et monsieur
françois mitterrand en direct dans ce
journal mais avant tout de suite donc
l'énoncé en détail des principales
mesures
objectif essentiel de ces mesures les
dépenses de santé ne doivent pas
augmenter plus vite que la richesse
nationale si notre production s'accroît
de 3 % d'une année sur l'autre et bien
le budget sécurité sociale augmentera de
3% et 2 3% seulement
il va donc s'agir de réduire par trois
le rythme actuel d'augmentation de
dépenses de santé pour cela les budgets
des hôpitaux publics seront plafonnées
si leurs charges augmentent plus que
prévu il appartiendra à chaque directeur
d'hôpital de prendre des mesures
d'économies il n'y aura pas de rallonge
budgétaire en fin d'année pour les
hôpitaux
le prix de journée des cliniques privées
sera bloquée et la carte sanitaire sera
strictement appliquée les médecins et
les dentistes verront le tarif de leur
consultation bloqués jusqu'en 1981 il
n'y aura donc pas d'augmentation du prix
des consultations en octobre et en
janvier prochain comme cela était prévu
ce blocage des revenus des professions
médicales rapportera un demi milliard de
francs à la sécurité sociale
pour sa part l'état prendra à sa charge
la formation des étudiants en médecine
c'est une contribution de l'ordre de 3 à
4 milliards de francs
en outre il prêtera 5 milliards de
francs à la sécurité sociale les
cotisations payées par les salariés et
certains autres assurés seront augmentés
de 1 %
cette cotisation supplémentaire aura un
caractère exceptionnel elle s'appliquera
sur l'ensemble du salaire
et cela pendant 18 mois exemple st si
vous touchez un salaire de 2000 francs
votre cotisation sociale augmentera de
20 francs
vous paierez dont une petite nation
total de 204 francs si vous gagnez 9000
francs votre cotisation augmentera de 90
francs ce qui vous fera le cotisation
totale de 660 francs
cette mesure rapportera 12 milliards de
francs à la sécurité sociale
et puis d'autres mesures seront prises
telles que une taxe sur la publicité
pharmaceutique et un relèvement prochain
des droits sous alcool et tabac
enfin les ordonnances de médecins
devront être faites en double exemplaire
dont une pour la sécurité sociale les
médecins n'auront plus le droit de
prescrire des médicaments pour une durée
supérieure à un mois bien visiblement à
l'énoncé de ces mesures martin à un
règne on a l'impression que tout le
monde à part les entreprises pour des
raisons économiques tout le monde va
payer un peu le déficit de la sécurité
sociale
pratiquement tout le monde ce plan
repose sur une série de principes qu'ils
ne mettent pas en cause le
fonctionnement de la sécurité sociale et
dans le premier de tous et la solidarité
personne n'est accusé tout le monde est
désormais parfaitement responsable
alors tout le monde va payer à deux
exceptions près toutes les entreprises
qui auront à payer d'autres charges le
chômage d'apprentissage etc et les non
salariés artisans et commerçants qui
sont qu'appartiennent une classe à part
et qui ont équilibré leur budget et qui
momentanément n'auront pas comme les
autres à payer 1 % de plus de
cotisations cotisation est certes un bon
point est plus que d'autres ceux qui
vivent de la santé et qui pousse plus ou
moins consciemment à la consommation
c'est-à-dire les médecins les
pharmaciens les dentistes les
industriels de la pharmacie et j'en
passe certainement mais qui auront de
façons diverses ou des prix bloqués ou
des taxes supplémentaires des taxes sur
le revenu etc qui permettront d'apporter
une quote-part au règlement immédiat des
problèmes de sécurité sociale deuxième
principe le respect de la médecine
libérale
on y reste attachée mais faut savoir ce
que contient le mot libéral désormais
c'est sans doute une liberté surveillée
ou tout du moins liberté réfléchi dit
dans ce troisième principe aucune mesure
ne touchera le remboursement des
prestations
si votre médecin vous fait une
ordonnance très longue encore
contestable elle vous sera remboursé
comme par le passé au moins pendant les
lys
moi du plan à court terme après ouvert
quatrième point est très important car
celui ci va sur le long terme on est
décidé à agir sur les comportements
comportement des usagers des
ordonnateurs des dépenses et des
gestionnaires de santé entendait aussi
les hôpitaux
alors ses plans sont à deux vitesses un
court terme 17 mois on vous dresse un
état actuel un long terme
on construit une autre façon de gérer la
santé car si on ne fait rien en 85
il y aura 75 milliards de jpy lors des
dates sont prises des concertations sont
à gaz et des décrets seront pris avant
le 1er septembre comme celui par exemple
du ticket modérateur d'ordre public
comme vous appartiennent
quand vous appartenez à une mutuelle en
plus de la sécurité sociale actuellement
vous pouvez être remboursés à 100% ce
sera flu vous aurez au moins toujours 5%
à payer ce responsable des bilans de six
mois en six mois alors des mesures
multiples parfois parcellaire en
mosaïque etc rade efficacité immédiate
d'intimidation psychologique je dirais
d'économies strictes mais dont on peut
se demander s'ils vont pouvoir être
efficace applicable pour les premières
si court terme sans remettre en cause
peut être la qualité des biens merci
martin alors cela mène tout de suite à
la première question qui devrait poser à
monsieur barreau ministre à la santé
merci d'être venus on dit jusqu'à
présent que la santé des français
n'avait pas de prix aujourd'hui on se
demande un petit peu si les économies ne
vont pas passer avant la santé des
français le sioniste non le ministre en
charge de ce dossier c'est d'abord le
ministre la santé et restent mises la
santé et tout ce plan est étudiée de
manière à ne pas toucher au principe de
solidarité qui est à la base la sécurité
sociale et à ne pas compromettre une
politique de santé qui est quand même
une des meilleures politiques du monde
et que nous voulons bien continuer mais
alors est ce que le médecin aura encore
toute liberté de prescription avec son
malade tout à fait liberté de
prescription c'est bien cela que nous
voulons sauver
nous ne saurions pas si nous ne prenons
pas des mesures aujourd'hui d'économies
et des mesures de freinage de la dépense
parce qu'à ce moment là
tôt ou tard avec le déficit prévisionnel
que vous
indiqué nous verrions à ce moment là
remise en cause de ce système
ce que nous voulons c'est garder
l'esprit du système c'est d'une médecine
ou le médecin est effectivement libre de
sa prescription mais contrôlé très
contrôlé le médecin doit regarder de
près aussi le coup de la prescription
il doit se sentir responsable car les
ressources nationales ne sont pas
infinies les français en ont assez bon
sens pour comprendre ça mais si le
billet vous sous-entendez que les
médecins prescrivent cointreau est
peut-être mal je ne vais pas là parler
des médecins en général pour les accusés
ça n'a aucun sens mais c'est vrai que
dans certains cas avec la complicité du
consultant parfois je connais des
consultants qui redemande au médecin des
prescriptions parce que il considère que
si on n'a pas beaucoup de médicaments on
n'est pas bien soigner ce qui va être le
vrai je ne vais pas là monsieur le
soutien au médecin pour apprécier mais
je dis qu'il ya parfois une complicité
des français devant certaines formes de
gaspillage
je suis mort parlons des hôpitaux
publics maintenant si vous voulez bien
vous avez bloqué les budgets de ces
hôpitaux ce que vous nous croyez vous
croyez que cette mesure est applicable
immédiatement
qu'est ce que certains hôpitaux ne sont
pas obligées de fermer certains de leurs
services
comprenons nous bien pour 79 nous en
restons au budget primitivement prévu
parce que c'est trop facile si vous
voulez de faire des budgets additionnels
et puis de voir la dépense ce sens volé
il y a un an nous étions un taux de
progression de 17% et maintenant nous
sommes un taux de progression de 23% des
dépenses
nous sommes bien obligés de dire
attention bon pour 79 on en restera au
budget initial et pour 80 on va préparer
les budgets en essayant de tenir compte
de ce que la ressource nationale et
richesses nationales croise un certain
rythme et que la dépense hospitalière
doit essayer de tenir compte de ce riz
et nous ferons ça avec les hospitaliers
cas je voudrais rendre hommage de
l'hôpital public
il a fait des efforts remarquables dans
ce pays mais aujourd'hui et vous le
savez il faut faire un effort il faut
pas que un service recommence les
analyses qui ont été faits par l'autre
services sont grotesques de service un
service on s'ignore dans certains cas il
faut savoir aussi qu'il peut y avoir
quelques lits qui sont
vous occupez et que parfois il vaut
mieux fermer quelques lits sous-occupés
pour permettre à l'hôpital de bien faire
tourner les lits qui sont nécessaires
qui répondent aux besoins de la
population vous avez indiqué que le
l'assurance automobile allait un peu
prendre le relais de la sécurité sociale
assurance maladie
pour ce qui concerne les accidents et
les séquelles de santé liés aux
accidents de la route
est ce que ce n'est pas une deuxième
façon de nous faire payer tout de même
parce que a priori l'assurance
automobile va prendre le relais mais
nous voulons nous adresser une opération
qui normalement ne doit pas se traduire
pour les assurés par un coup quelconque
c'est une mesure de clarification nous
parlons du risque d'assurance maladie ne
le confonde pas avec le risque accidents
de la route
et c'est uniquement une mesure de
clarification car si nous voulons
surveiller l'évolution des dépenses
maladie faut parler des dépenses de
maladie et nous envisageons d'ailleurs
dans l'esprit de ce que nous a proposé
le parlement de voir si certains risques
sont liés à des sports dangereux ne
pourront pas eu eux aussi être séparés
nation et l'alcoolisme et l'alcoolisme
évidemment puisque vous savez que nous
allons augmenter les taxes sur l'alcool
et que je continuerai avec et l'énergie
l'abri de prévention les patrons et
certains non salariés ne vont pas verser
au pot comme mascotte et sociales alors
pourquoi
bon ben ils vont pas rester là sans rien
faire 1 les chefs d'entreprise ils nous
diront pas que parce qu'on a augmenté
les charges sociales ils ne peuvent pas
embaucher
il n'en profiteront pas pour différer
l'embauchage que nous leur demandons
chef d'entreprise c'est chaque fois que
c'est possible de prendre quelqu'un de
plus dans leur entreprise c'est ça leur
contribution elle est essentielle et
c'est pour cela que nous n'avons pas
demandé de ce que tu es là un effort de
contribution
mais il ya une contrepartie celle
embauches devraient intervenir un petit
peu une seconde dans cette discussion
comme aux néophytes comme un français
moyen on a déjà demandé aux français aux
salariés français au début de cette
année une rallonge à leurs cotisations
on vient de leur en demander une seconde
est ce que c'est la dernière fois qu'on
le fait ou est ce que il va y avoir un
plan ou d'autres dents
ceci nous avons prévu un programme de 18
mois c'est une politique de calendrier
c'est un rendez vous que nous donnons
les uns aux autres si les français ne
veulent pas continuer à verser des
contributions exceptionnelles
il faut qu'ils acceptent une certaine
discipline et tous nous savons notre bon
sens nous le dit nous savons bien qu'il
y ait ici ou là des gaspillages un excès
de consommation qu'il faut freiner et
qui n'eut pas pour autant d'ailleurs un
signe de bonne santé
alors je dis que cela dépend de la
réussite de notre effort de discipline
car ce qui est de nouveau dans le plan
d'aujourd'hui c'est que la priorité est
donnée au freinage des dépenses
monsieur le ministre comment se fait-il
que les chiffres de sécurité sociale
varie aussi rapidement et manière aussi
importante il y a quelques semaines on
parlait d'un déficit de 2 milliards 4
que les passes à dix milliards
maintenant on parle de 24 heures est ce
qu'il ya vraiment une comptabilité la
scic antisociales non nous n'avons pas
il faut le reconnaître encore un tableau
de bord clair et net
est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est que 1.2
dépenses supplémentaires immédiatement
c'est un milliard de dépenses et vous
voyez que quand on passe comme ça a été
le cas depuis le mois de septembre
l'année dernière d'un taux de
progression de 17 à 23
vous voyez tout de suite le déficit se
creusera très vite ses ministres si les
partenaires de santé n'accepte pas votre
plan vous irez l'épreuve de force
mais voyez-vous les professions de santé
ont un grand intérêt à ce que nous
réussissions ils ont un intérêt
fondamental c'est vraiment le moyen de
préserver une l'exercice libéral de la
médecine une liberté de prescription et
je suis convaincu que le corps médical
comprend qu'il faudra négocier une
convention qui soit conforme aux
exigences d'aujourd'hui qui prennent en
compte le prix de la tarification de
l'acte mais aussi le nombre d'actes il y
a des médecins dans ce pays qui font
beaucoup plus qu d'actes que d'autres il
faut tenir compte de cela et nous
tiens donc on a une nouvelle convention
que nous discuterons mais tout ça va se
faire dans la concertation je le répète
il n'y a pas d'accusé ce soir il ya
simplement une efforts de tous pour
réussir cette maîtrise des dépenses de
santé pour pouvoir conquis du jeu
ministre les partis de gauche notamment
vous accuse de vouloir démanteler la
sécurité à la joie constitué médecine
des riches mais sinon mélange crois que
j'ouvre un brevet chaîne aurait pu être
tenté de le faire on aurait pu par
exemple faire que le ticket modérateur
c'est à dire le mode de remboursement
soit brutalement modifié
ça voulait dire que le français qui
n'est pas adhérent une mutuelle qui est
malade aurait payé beaucoup plus que le
français qui gagnent plus d'argent qui
est à une mutuelle et qui n'est pas
malade
nous avons refusé tout ça alors on peut
faire tous les reproches sur ce premier
temps ou même à long terme notre plante
18 mois ville a gardé l'esprit mme dati
n'est social à éviter tout démantèlement
et ça je crois qu'il faut le souligner
parce que nous avons vraiment chercher
tous les moyens d'éviter de toucher à la
sodida monsieur nice et après est ce
qu'on ne va pas quand même jour
valeureux non remboursement du petit
risque
l'avenir dira si nous réussissons à
cette maîtrise je pense que nous
pourrons continuer effectivement les
remboursements mais l'avenir le dira et
les assurés sociaux le drian
ce que nous voulons actuellement c'est
arrivé un freinage de la dépense pour le
moment il n'est pas question et nous
verrons mutins